my oldest daughter is 6 months we're in
the elevator in our apartment building
and she had a pacifier in her mouth and
so this woman gets on and she's like
looking at the baby she goes how old's
the baby and I was like oh she's 6
months and then she goes isn't she a
little old for a
pacifier and then the mother of my
children Jasmine pulled the emergency
stop on the elevator with me my baby
Jasmine and this woman on the elevator
and she goes what the [__] did you just
say to me and my baby she goes why don't
you mind your [__] business before I put
a passive fire in your mouth [__] and I
was like oh my God so we get down to the
lobby and the fire trucks are pulling in
and then the fireman he goes why did you
pull the emergency she goes because this
[__] right here told me that my
daughter is too old to have a pacifier
he goes That's a $500 ticket for just
you know pulling that and calling us
without a real emergency and she was
like I'm sorry and then he goes nah I
[__] hate these people the fire
department they need to mind their
[__] business right I said yeah he
goes no ticket f it have a good day he
goes I should give her the ticket for
being a [__]